hallo hallo gehts gut aber ein bisschen
enttäuscht warum wir haben heute kein
ticket bekommen und es ist keine
katastrophe und und was katastrophen
kleine katastrophe haben auch spaß
gehabt ja und das dorf war sehr schön
aber die leute waren sehr nett der
johannes hat uns viel beigebracht
herr ein bisschen streng wir müssen
richtig arbeiten aber und die natur der
himmel war sehr schön aber das war nicht
so freundlich später war es auch schon
und viele verschiedene trauben probiert
spätburgunder
kalt teller die die erste sorte war die
zweite war riesling der dritte ich habe
auch eine flasche wein für meinen vater
gekauft als ein geschenk es war ein
geschenk dass mein vater kann sich auf
einen kleinen freund